and other country music festival
happening tonight in honor of one
October also at the Clark County
Amphitheater Madison Kimbrough spoke
with those involved and joins us in The
Newsroom tonight with the latest Madison
yeah known as the Remember music
festival it's meant to raise funds in
honor of the lives lost from that tragic
night of the Route 91 Harvest Festival
now the Country Strong project and
Stoney's Rockin country hosting this
first time festival at the Clark County
Amphitheater income remuneration of the
fifth anniversary of the shooting and to
support the one October Memorial the
event which started at one had music
performance along with music and vendors
selling merchandise we spoke to a
musician who experienced that tragic Day
in 2017 but is back in Vegas tonight to
perform
the beginning of the day was just a high
you know and then obviously it went you
know to a low but as I said you know
through the evening and what happened uh
after the fact I got to meet so many
good people and and people that was I
saw a lot of people taking care of you
know everybody else and it was a lot of
love and embrace that you don't get to
see a whole lot in the world I feel like
a country strong project is a group of
survivors who host annual reunions in
Las Vegas each year but again this is
the first time that organizers are
hosting an event like this to the public
now in addition a special tribute will
be held at 10 pm tonight to honor those
who have passed away in the attack now
as you can see the event which is still
open for entry and selling tickets we'll
conclude tonight at midnight all the
proceeds from sales will go to charity